[Music]
i know those floors guess who's back i
recognize that infrastructure
dayton's back guys that is uh
does that house look familiar
guess what
christmas our dealer came through with
two new dayton videos oh my god there's
two there's two i guarantee you we
probably won't even get it no we will
get to the second one it's a nice little
it's been so long since i've done any
date and i'm super scared to do two
dating okay so let me read the title you
ready here's the title here's the title
ready
skinhead enabler sister and husband
right downstairs not on speaking terms
with me seven years nazi violence to me
ignored
now for those newer listeners that might
be who's been watching off dayton go to
the clip channel there's entire dayton
hypernova saga playlist you could watch
he is quick rundown a legend around here
quick rundown dayton we've we found it
years ago he was 33 33 years old he's
trans male to female but he still dates
chicks he's an artist he used to blame
his brother he lives with his parents he
used to blame his brother for beating
him up when he wore dresses even though
the entire
lgbtq dayton community has publicly
stated we read a public statement from
one of like the groups over there
totally disavowing this guy he's a piece
of [ __ ] he picks on his elderly parents
he takes her credit cards so he could
buy dresses on
on amazon and health burritos so he
could start his boutique store
where it's going to be donation only if
you want to give money and he thinks
that's a business you know we're going
to pay rent and stuff and and if you get
him the pizza that he doesn't like
oh boy oh boy is he going to be mad
so anyway
dayton hypernova he's back even if you
want him to drive your car because
yeah
oh yeah oh yeah
tonight's recording his sister and his
parents downstairs
[Music]
he actually ate
big vicious apple okay which is a shock
it looks like found serial killer
footage it really does
this makes this gives me anxiety too
because it makes me feel like i'm like
hiding i'm not i'm somewhere i'm not
supposed to be
so
you know how i get rid of it
you imagine the metal gear solid theme
yes that does help but i usually do the
mission impossible one um
this is um
what there's what you hear him saying
down there is he's secretly recording
them somebody asking how's dayton doing
today and somebody goes he's doing a
little bit like what
[Music]
which is a shock and yeah i went to all
of our last night i went to olive garden
last night big spenders
he secretly records his family
it just made me really sad they're like
all concerned about him and [ __ ] exactly
and he is and he is well as you're about
to see
here we go you ready it's been a while
since we've seen the face
it's been a while
bake it
arrogant
older sister i gotta dust off those
bingo cards
his downstairs with her kids and my
brother-in-law
well they both allowed all that violence
to happen to me by a skinhead okay well
it's all in the past right they continue
to come over to the house on a regular
basis and not speak with me he's shaking
the phone's shaking what's he on bro his
hands are shaking look last time that
they did speak with me they physically
harass me look how much is functioning
physically i could just be psych meds
yeah they might be and cussed me out
went crazy i mean right in front of our
parents right in front of mom and dad
they went crazy at me it was all about
the skinhead and all about the violence
that happened to me and me speaking out
about it it also could just be him being
a [ __ ] lunatic yeah it's probably
that mostly that and they basically you
know they go from crazy mode to
completely neutral
laughing air power everything downstairs
like
yeah it's called living your life even
when we can't just spend the rest of our
life mourning one or two ass weapons you
got from a guy who died two years ago
at some point
we got to have dinner and stuff right
like this is that fair but it's not even
that the other part is it's like
before this guy
definitely doesn't record as much as he
used to used to every day we'd have a
new dayton video that i was recording
every day was a machine
um and
he never caught any video footage of his
brother hitting him but we did catch
three cases of him hitting his brother
once was on christmas when he broke a
full wine glass over his head
laughs in life you know like there's
nothing like happy-go-fucking [ __ ]
ever against then leave
like basically he's 36 now bro
and there they are they're walking away
from the house now they're basically
letting my parents babysit their kids
yeah because your parents are very nice
and it's their family it's their
grandchildren
i i don't get why you're like it's this
is one of the things for some of the
people that didn't watch yeah the soccer
experience this saga is like his family
is pretty much like like they're you
know everybody's flawed everybody's
families but they're like
quaint people that get along and like
every video is them in the background
with the babies and they're eating lunch
or having a barbecue and they're all
like you know it's a family that all
still stays in touch and they all live
in the same block it's kind of wholesome
and then it's just this guy
who's who just makes everyone miserable
remember the aluminum foil art he did in
the attic you remember that where he
just went through rolls and rolls of
aluminum foil it was art
you know
the parents that allow the skinhead you
know to live in this house
you know they allow they allow them to
babysit the children so i just keep a
record of all this because i'm living in
the house still i'm still living here
i'm keeping a record of every time those
people enter the house
and you're either being not a judge i i
ain't judging
like because you know what i mean but
like on some real [ __ ] i would not leave
my [ __ ] kids in that house alone not
only not with him
dude i would i would not leave my kids
there i don't give a [ __ ] who else is
there no
only towards people or behaving the way
they're behaving like in these normal
normal circumstances
of you know behaving completely neutral
and behaving in such a gaslighting
manner gaslighting that everything's
normal and there's never crazy
incidences towards the trans person that
house who was getting beat by a man
twice my size
shaved his head light crate and it did
crazy [ __ ] in the name of trump
named mike pence all that crazy [ __ ]
is anyone following this this train of
thought is trump what does trump and
mike pence have to do with your brother
beating you he did to me all that [ __ ]
that induced post-traumatic stress
disorder
from all of the violence i mean you know
the ptsd is still a problem even if it's
a guy hypocrisy is the biggest problem
doesn't live here anymore it has passed
away from covet exposure from the
parents who went on multiple vacations
during the cove pandemic he was also
terrified of covet like uh very vaccines
available to anybody at that time
the vaccines don't work came back and
he was on it
and actually uh the vaccine has actually
been known now to exacerbate eczema yeah
i know
could you imagine oh no his house must
look like [ __ ] like a snow globe
[Music]
it's just [ __ ] skin flakes everywhere
no thank you no thank you no thank you
no thank you
a [ __ ] snow [ __ ] shaking
oh [ __ ] dude
no compromise you look like a girl from
call out
all of this extreme alcohol was moved to
seven years that he was living here
beating the [ __ ] out of me and being a
wreck to the family
a mess
so i just keep it on record i mean it's
goddamn a mess it's a goddamn mess of a
family of bigots
awful
i barely even [ __ ] care anymore it's
so [ __ ] cuddleful
hypocrites who like do that kind of [ __ ]
it's absolutely disgusting
well
i think you're pretty disgusting
oh man that felt good i haven't had a
hit at dayton in a while yeah man that
was good now guess what
for tomorrow
we have a oh boy this is the big one 16
minute video i'll tell you the title my
right-wing dad listens to trump's
re-election campaign after seven years
of a skinhead beating me at
home he's got some he's starting to
write some like fallout boy panic at the
disco title at this point